all right well it is now time to talk
about
founders day as we celebrate founder's
day here at eight news now it's an
annual donation drive as we mark our
company's 25th anniversary
and help two amazing non-profits john
mcholman is live this afternoon at our
drop zone here at
channel 8 where generous viewers have
been stopping by all day bianca good
afternoon to you
hey good morning afternoon john it feels
still like morning because we've been
working hard i mean take a look at these
two bins
just for three square we've got folks
been dropping off food non-perishable
items and we really want to thank you
all because this
none of this would be possible without
your generous heart it's going to
organizations like free square and
salvation army we had one woman drop off
some professional
clothes we need some more children's
clothes so little emily little isaiah
you know kids grow like weeds
send over their items and of course
water we know that is essential right
now during the summertime matter of fact
we had a guy who dropped off cases of
water
take a listen 84
cases on a pallet for three square in
your donation program here
we really admire what three squares done
during the pandemic for the kids
and we felt we wanted to contribute to
it you're telling me that you're putting
out a challenge
right now putting out a challenge to all
the ppe
distributors special tool distributors
in the vegas valley
meet or exceed what we got
definitely a mic drop type of moment
this morning he really started off
strong for us
and we need you to finish off strong
again we're here at 3228 channel 8 drive
right here
near the encore wind resorts world right
across the street so
if you're on your lunch break stop by
the store get some cases of water if
you've got some clothes that need to be
donated in the trunk of your car
bring them down here we need your
donations because all this is going to
the salvation army
and three square they do so much to keep
us fed and our families fed our kids fed
in need across the valley going to send
it back to you john and we're here till
6 pm
32 28 channel a drive yeah indeed bianca
thank you we love seeing all of our
viewers come by it's been fantastic this
morning we've had a lot of people come
by already
now if you cannot make it here to
channel 8 today we understand
you can also donate directly to our
partner charities again salvation army
and three square food bank you see those
qr codes on your screen
scan them now with your phone or you can
text the numbers you see on your screen
there
that is another way that you can help
these fine nonprofits here in the valley
on our founders day